do not play CS2 until you've enabled
this feature it is called a jump bind
and what it's going to do is it's going
to allow you to land utility in
previously unable places setting one up
is slightly different in CS2 than csgo
so pay attention so all you're going to
do is you're going to locate the drive
on which your Counterstrike is located
this is the crucial part do not go into
CS go go into game once you're in game
you open csgo you go into the config
file you're going to make a document
you're going to open it and you're going
to copy and paste this command console
function file you're going to go to save
as you're going to make sure you check
all files and you're going to name the
file CFG you're going to open CS2 and
you are going to Simply type exec auto
exec whatever you've named the file what
that's going to do is it's going to give
you a fully serviceable jump on that
makes it so you don't actually have to
release left click whenever you throw a
nade just press your key happy fragen